au niveau des régionales quatre listes
seront présentes sur ce second tour en
ile de france la liste sortante avec
valérie pécresse arrivé premier avec 35
points 94 % des suffrages exprimés
julien bayou sera également présent sur
ce second tour le chef de file d'europe
écologie les verts en ile de france
annoncé l'union des trois listes de
gauche
la sienne avec celle de la socialiste
audrey pulvar et clémentine autain de
rfi les trois avaient obtenu plus de 10%
des voix sur ce premier tour ce
rassemblement va se faire donc c'est
très très bien et se et ça nous permet
de pouvoir espérer encore de prendre
cette région on retrouvera également
jordan bardella du rassemblement
national qui a totalisé 13 12% sur ce
premier tour et la liste et les roues
avec laurent saint martin et ses 11 76%
pour les départementales dans les
yvelines la droite menée par pierre
bédier réalisera-t-elle un nouveau grand
chelem comme en 2015 les listes
estampillées ensemble pour les yvelines
sont largement en tête dans plusieurs
cantons comme à pau c'est karl olive et
suzanne jaune et ou encore à chatou avec
eric dumoulin et stéphanie tiers seuls
les cantons trappe rambouillet montier
bretonne et vers l'est sur scène
pourrait leur échapper
la perspective de faire le grand chelem
d'auge avait dit qu'elle serait plus
compliqué on pouvait pas se donner
d'autres objectifs on ne peut pas se
donner d'autres objectifs rien nantes
bien entendu n'est perdu mais on voit
bien dans trois ou quatre cantons ça va
être un peu tendu serré et que on aura
les résultats tard dans la nuit de
dimanche à lundi prochain
le rassemblement national tentera de
jouer les trouble fête sur ce second
tour le parti sera présent dans deux
duels à mantes la jolie et à bonnières
sur seine
nous souhaitons mobiliser l'électorat du
premier tour mais également tous les
autres fonctionnent east il faut savoir
que 73 % de notre électorat ne s'est pas
déplacé au premier tour donc si cet
électorat se mobilisent se bouge et se
déplacent nous sommes pourquoi pas
encore en capacité de remporter ces deux
cantons en tout cas c'est l'objectif
les écologistes tenteront de s'emparer
de rambouillet le duo d
jutier et patrice à millau est en
embuscade juste derrière le binôme
d'ensemble pour les yvelines c'est une
preuve de l'envy d'écologie et
maintenant il faut il faut amplifier ce
mouvement lors du second tour dimanche
prochain pour porter l'écologie aux
responsabilités enfin la république en
marche tentera de l'emporter sur le
canton de versailles
un seul secteur où le parti est encore
présent le duo laurent de bastin dr
francine on va se confronter au binôme
claire chaillou fora et olivier de la
sphère de la liste de droite
ep y